talking about the far eastern
philosophies i was just wondering if you
ever practiced a kung fu or any of the
other martial arts
kung fu yes bruce lee was a great friend
of mine and he uh
we used to work out together for a long
time
uh it was very close we were very close
friends he's a very interesting
gentleman
bruce oh yes he was a groovy guy yeah
i was very sorry to see him go what do
you think made him so unique
uh well he related everything his whole
life was related to martial arts
uh he lived breathed fought
moved everything was dedicated to his
the highest principle of his own
self-evolution he created himself
bruce lee was a little chinese guy who
demanded of himself
great excellence i mean he he was a
true artist in that respect he created
himself
and that's what i think he was an
unusual man he was uh
he was beautiful he uh
i don't know what to say about him you
know because of the he was so
he's the perfection that he achieved uh
was awe-inspiring i mean he was the
fastest moving person you've ever seen
and you'd reach out and
he was like all over the place
we used to work out of his place and we
had a 700 pound bag
hung on a big l iron you know or
what they call them stuck in his patio
and it would s
spring and he would kick that thing and
double it over
and uh i would kick it and it would
double me over yeah
[Music]
but he would boom get that thing to
swing and back and forth and pop it
and pop it he was amazing really amazing
and he's a great loss a loss to me i'm
i miss him daily